i very much plan to continue to speak up
on behalf of women
in public life as well as our children
by seeking better protections for
everyone on social media
when i was at school bullying occurred
but when children stepped off the bus
their home was a safe place
and today our young people have no
escape the bullies are following them
right into their bedroom and we must act
mr speaker a former member of this house
said to me last week that my closing
speech
should be in the style of father ted
crilley when he received the golden
cleric award
but after a moment of reflection i
thought perhaps not
now some of the younger faces in here
would be puzzled by who father ted was
and even more puzzled
by the name of the award but suffice to
say
just like all politicians who resign i
will now
spend more time with my family so my
lovely mom
my darling husband and my three beloved
children
will see more of me whether they like it
or not
it's just as well mr speaker i am such a
good daughter
wife and mother those of us in public
life
know that we cannot fully function
without the support of our loved ones
and i've had that support in abundance
i wish my successors as party leader and
first minister well and i want to thank
politicians from right across the
political spectrum
for their good wishes i've been
overwhelmed
even some in the naughty corner found
something good to say
if only we'd sell all those nice things
a few years ago it would save us a lot
of time
mr speaker my reflections today will be
broader more than personal
with an eye to the future of the
assembly and northern ireland
as part of the united kingdom my time as
northern ireland's first minister may
have come to a close abruptly
but i remain someone with a passion for
service for northern ireland
and for the union this particular
chapter may be closing
but i intend to write some more in the
years ahead for i have
unfinished business to ensure northern
ireland succeeds
in its new century i believe strongly in
the good sense of the people of northern
ireland to continue to recognize the
value of our place
within the united kingdom as a
distinctive and
integral element of that union of
nations
a uk that has seen us through the worst
ravages of the covet 19 pandemic
with unprecedented financial support our
incomparable national health service
and a national vaccination program that
is the envy
of the rest of the world now as you're
aware mr speaker i was first elected
to the northern ireland assembly in 2003
and since then i've had the great
privilege to be the representative for
fermanagh
and south churu my home constituency and
somewhere i am tremendously proud of
both in terms of its diverse population
and its beautiful countryside i was
pleased to show it off
one last time as first minister when
myself and the deputy first minister
hosted
the british irish council meeting on
friday past
in 2007 when devolution returned i was
appointed minister for the environment
and from there i went on to become
minister for enterprise trade and
investment a rule i loved as it allowed
me to speak positively about
and be an advocate for northern ireland
across the world
the highlight was 2012 when we showcased
northern ireland during
our time our police campaign
transforming invest northern ireland
building up our tourism industry
inviting international investors to come
to northern ireland
and creating more and better jobs for
our young people
are all achievements that i look back
upon with pride
oscar wilde who was educated in
fermanagh royal school suggested and i
quote
a dreamer is one who can only find his
way by moonlight
and his punishment is that he sees the
dawn before the rest of the world
close quote and throughout my time in
economy and since
i have continuously been impressed by
the ingenuity
innovation and aspiration of all our
people but especially
our young people i say to those
potential young leaders
hold on to your dreams because by doing
so
you're halfway there i was appointed to
finance and personnel ministry in 2015
and then in january 2016 became first
minister for northern ireland
something a little girl growing up in
fermanagh could scarcely have
countenanced
i trust my contribution has served as an
encouragement to others
and the role of females in public life
is something i will continue to champion
following the 2016 assembly election mr
speaker i agreed a joint statement for
the new elected
executive with the then deputy first
minister martin mcginnis
and this was commonly described as a
joint commitment to
getting down to business a statement of
intent
to focus on the issues of common concern
not the wedges
that can divide and to show once and for
all that the evolution
could deliver change not just more of
the same
it is my deepest regret that the
opportunity to fulfill that purpose
would be denied by a series of events
when faced with false allegations of
corruption
i defended myself vigorously to clear my
name
and no one should have to tolerate such
assaults on their character
but misleading interviews and salacious
claims that would not survive
the glare of an inquiry created a
febrile atmosphere that coincided
with the declining health of martin
mcginnis the result
a crisis that led to the unnecessary
loss
of devolution lost years for northern
ireland
and a period when public services
inevitably slumped backwards
alongside ongoing negotiations to
restore the evolution where no sign of a
workable agreement was evident
we secured the democratic unionist
party's confidence and supply agreement
to help fill the political volume vacuum
and public service consequences
over one billion pounds extra in
resources was provided in those years in
key areas like health
education and jobs but the solutions it
provided
and difficulties that mitigated were
still outstripped by the problems from
having no functioning assembly or
executive
that confidence and supply agreement
will leave a legacy
but all also highlights our challenges
150 million has been ruled out via
project stratum to bring broadband to
rural areas and leave northern ireland
as the best connected region in europe
and when completed
the project will be transformational to
our economy
we ensured the purse strings were
loosened by treasury to enable 500
million
to be used to help shared housing and
education schemes
we delivered 50 million over five years
to help
mental health and i note that money has
been critical in recent announcements by
the health minister
sadly broader politics in northern
ireland between
the uk and ireland and the uk and the eu
is out of balance an imbalance created
by the protocol in any negotiation when
one of those at the table is perceived
as weak
the clear temptation is for others to
take full advantage
however such short-term advantage comes
at the cost
of long-term harm to relationships
it is not a real partnership
and in an imbalance and an instability
is built in
that will fester and deteriorate and if
brussels continue to think that the
protocol is enough
they are in denial imbalance
and instability in the context of
northern ireland is a truly
dangerous cocktail northern ireland is
part of the united kingdom and needs to
be treated as such
and if the eu does not then the uk
will have a practical political and
moral obligation to act
to protect the everyday life of everyone
in northern ireland
so i may no longer be in the position of
political leadership mr speaker but rest
assured
i will contribute in whatever way i can
to see northern ireland advance socially
politically
economically and culturally as part of
the uk
i firmly believe strong functioning and
successful
devolution is vital to this and to
building the success
of northern ireland and what it is
capable of in its new century
mr speaker in closing samuel beckett
also educated in fermanagh in waiting
for god
wrote let us do something while we have
the chance
it is not every day that we are needed
not indeed that we personally are needed
and he continued but at this place at
this moment of time
all mankind is us whether we like it or
not
let us make the most of it let's be
generous
our lord taught us the parable of the
good samaritan and i'm sure
we've all heard it but remember two
people passed by
they closed their eyes to the injured
jewish man
now mr speaker i haven't always made the
right calls
none of us are perfect but at the end of
the parable our lord asks
who is your neighbor the one who stopped
to offer help
remember stopping meant the samaritan
reaching out across the religious divide
and it also meant him reaching into his
own pocket
and paying a price to provide shelter
for the injured man
our lord concludes the parable by saying
go
and do likewise mr speaker let us be
good neighbors
thank you for allowing me to speak
overnight